[Music]
bare-knuckle boxing this is fist
fighting
anything can happen at any given time
[Music]
seventy-three norm bare-knuckle fighting
if he doubted boat alignment
[Music]
[Music]
my day job is construction work I
retired from professional boxing a year
and a half ago
I got into the underground circuit I
probably have 100 feet fights they
remind the vertical fights underground
bare-knuckle boxing is a secret world
it's like the forbidden food it's
illegal yes uh yeah because it's not
sanction and regulated it's Underground
mano-a-mano it's man-to-man you bring
these two guys in they toe the line 18
inches from each other and they start
they start punching each other right
away
there is no cushion on the hands there's
no cushion on ahead there's nothing to
fight the shots it's the purest form of
combat sports that there is under ground
rules
there is no bells there's no rounds
there's no judges the referee
there's no dirtiness no head button no
biting no album smashing
well if I stop pretty simple you knock
about he's out
the guys getting a good beating the
Bloods come out of him he can't defend
himself referees gonna stop him to say
boxing there's all drawers drawers is
for chickenshits everybody gets paid to
fight but the winner gets substantially
more money pays can really go anywhere
from these from 500 hours up to $50,000
for one fight finding on who's involved
who's backing it who may be putting a
little money on the side it's always a
worry in the underground world he gets
rated and stopped you know you're not
supposed to be having them we obviously
have concerns that the authorities will
come in and and put an end to it but we
try to be very protective very secretive
about how we do these things we don't
advertise it anywhere like we're not
have a website that come watch us here
it's nothing like that
it's word of mouth we say why wear jeans
and might beater for me if I'm fightin
and God forbid let's see summer rain
didn't come in well I just put a coat on
and everybody else that room sometimes
it's in a warehouse sometimes it's in
the basement of a retail store sometimes
it's in you know at the back of a
parking lot somewhere I fought in
warehouses next to grocery stores where
people was maybe with their little
daughters going down in Aisle number
nine oblivia to a bloodbath next door
it's not just a couple hundred dollars
you know some people do some really big
money bets on these things
that's why these things really take
place and that's how we're in a position
that we really try to evolve this thing
looking to take the underground version
of bare-knuckle boxing modified a little
bit and take a mainstream legalizing it
getting this sanction and getting into a
couple different states and we really
feel that we're gonna just take over to
combat sport industry
I don't do it for the money I do it for
the love of the sport and the money
comes along with it's a it's a bonus we
get fighters really from all different
walks of life they want to be the
toughest guy out there they want to be
the best fighter they want to make as
much money as they possibly can
I'm a former United States Marine
they're doing this what about over the
span of a year now
we'll probably love paying a little bit
more than ordinary people it's not for
thee I would say the average person to
want to tribe at the end of the day
you're asking to get hurt I've had
eleven bare-knuckle fights all ended in
way of knockout undefeated so far
I'm on construction company part seven
days a week
have three daughters I take care of a
really rough area all every day growing
up pretty much might as well make money
doing it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I fought four times for the world title
I thought the best fighters in the world
all those men I lost the professional
boxing I swear to god I'm telling you
today not one of them will last five
minutes me on the street he's been doing
it since he was a baby
really he is a legend Baron aquabox
I'm 73 and all bare-knuckle fighting
[Applause]
[Music]
the hardest opt-in it was definitely
that guy he's it's hard to sit there's
no doubt in my mind that this will be a
premier sport and that's why I'm trying
to get it legalized and get it
sanctioned and get it regulated got a
lot of people out there that are really
pushing forward and we have some you
know some may say or some negative
statements that we get but it's just
like what happened with the biggest MMA
company in the world they flew under the
radar they did in this state and in this
state they did what they had to do till
people roll yo you see that it was a
street fight in a case let's do this
thing and then everybody wanted to watch
it respect
respect people that's made this thing is
like human cockfighting is terrible it's
not I know within the next coming months
at the latest you will be seeing very
novel boxing on television
guaranteed
what would you rather watch right now on
TV bare-knuckle boxing our glove boxing
there's the answer
[Music]
everybody can't turn away from a
bare-knuckle fight
they can
[Music]